[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of the most frequent
performance problems
your users will
notice is how your app
reacts when moving from a
great network connection
to a bad one.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And if your app isn't properly
adapting to network latency
during the day, your users
will blame your app rather than
their connection.
The truth is that
the internet is
made of a bunch of crazy moving
parts, or a series of tubes,
if you're a senator.
Anyhow, basically, requests
made from your phone
have to hit a local
cell tower, which
then gets routed to the
service provider's server.
And then, it may hit a local
data proxy for that provider,
before going out
onto the Internet
and connecting the main data
server, which then needs
to decode the response,
fetch the data,
and then send that back,
only to return the data back
to your cache's ISP server,
and then finally to the phone itself.
Basically, it's a
lot of moving parts,
and a bottleneck
can be anywhere.
And since you don't
control all those stages,
the best you can do is make sure
that your application properly
adjusts to how it works based on
the connectivity of the device.
This involves two
things. Number one,
getting information
about the speed
and performance of the
network, and number two,
designing your app to respond
to changes in bad latency environments.
Now, the first is easier
to do than you might think.
Simply grab the
connection manager
and determine if you're
on a mobile network.
>From there, a quick call
to grab the network subtype
gives you an enumeration
for what type of network
you're connected to.
A handy lookup table then lets
you know what kind of network
you're dealing with,
and what to expect
as the best possible
bandwidths and latency.
But in truth, that value gives
you the best case scenario.
See, in the wild, you're going
to get much worse results.
Even though your user
might be on an LTE network,
there may be a problem
with a slow data server,
resulting in maybe
double the time it
would normally take on that
network for that request.
So a more accurate,
although more complex,
solution is to evaluate the
time it takes to grab responses
from your network.
For example, if
you know that all
of your thumbnails in your list
view are 128 by 128 pixels,
then you have a general
sense they should be about 1K
in size, which should,
on the given network only
take a certain amount
of time to download.
You can then average the true
cost of these fetches over time
to give you a better sense of
what the real network conditions are
and how they are changing as
the user moves through their day.
Once you get this
information, you then need to
decide how to design
your app to handle it.
As a simple approach, you can
define two thresholds and three
buckets of classification.
If your latency is less than,
say, a lower threshold of 60
milliseconds to fetch
an asset, then your user
is on a great connection.
You may be able to be more
aggressive about the amount
of data that you pre-fetch
and less of aggressive
about things like caching.
However, if it takes less
than the upper threshold,
then you may not be
in the best spot.
So you need to become more
aggressive about batching
and caching, and take advantage
of how often you request data.
And if they're above
the max threshold,
well then, you should find ways
to defer requests until later,
when there might be a
better network connection,
or change the UI so
that not fetching all
the thumbnail images isn't
such a huge, jarring problem.
But the truth is,
that these thresholds
won't work for every user.
And in fact, you're
going to need
to put a bit of elbow grease in
to find the correct thresholds
for the 50th percentile, 90th
percentile, and 99th percentile
of the connections that
your users are actually on,
which is actually a
pretty large engineering
project, but critically
important for your app
to remain responsive and magical
in high latency environments.
Now rather than
waiting for the users
to focus on slow
connections to complain,
it's better to start designing
and testing bad bandwidth
on your app early.
You can test how high latency
impacts your applications
by throttling the bandwidth when
you're running the Android Emulator.
Or you can check
out third party apps
like AT&T's Network Attenuator.
In both cases, you can
see how your app responds
when latency goes sky
high, which you should
be doing with everything.
Honestly, testing performance
on the slowest hardware, worst
networks, and most
insane conditions,
is the best way to ensure a
stable, consistent performance
for your users.
Of course, you'll need to watch
the rest of our
Android Performance Pattern videos
to see what to fix.
And join our Google+ community
to get advice from other developers
in the same boat.
Trust me, your users
will thank you.
So keep calm.
Profile your code.
And always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]